good morning everyone I hope you're all
well thank you all for joining me this
this morning I'm I'm 1:00 tomorrow I can
leave the house that I'm in because I've
been in a lockdown because someone
started showing symptoms in our
household so super excited to get in the
outside but really excited to have all
of you here just to let you all know
there's over 100 recruiters in here so
and I want this to be interactive I want
you guys to get involved as much as
possible so just a bit of housekeeping
and where I'd love all of you to get
involved and answer the questions that I
ask is yeah where Tessa is just messaged
so and let me just show you answer my
questions here so in that public chat
we're on 10 morning obviously you guys
can speak but if I sort of asked you
guys to sort of share your thoughts or
what do you think that is where I would
love you to put your message and then
the other part is you should be able to
see a Q&A and so I've already put a
question here so let me do it again
questions article questions questions
here so you can send your questions on
the Q&A part whenever you want and I'll
I'll keep an eye on those and I can
answer them as I go through this but
what you can do is actually up vote the
question so you can see the questions
I've got here I cannot vote them so if
you see people ask questions that you
really like then um you can go in there
and our ask your questions so that's a
bit of housekeeping and as I said I want
it to be interactive and but why don't
we just start everyone's already sent
hello why don't we just start
and with I'd love to know where you guys
are based where you're currently basing
yourself out of this morning and how
your Monday was so feel free to jump in
the the public chat and just share where
you're currently based and what how your
Monday was how is how was everyone's
Monday being yesterday and where the
hell are you recruiting owls Phillip
Steve Bristol James Brighton Watford
how are your Monday's long well Green
massive okay Birmingham Brighton good
morning from evening from Melbourne Emma
thank you so much between then based in
Amsterdam Monday was good Monday was
productive that's good Hartford [ __ ] out
of my kitchen Monday was good picked up
okay low scoots up in our box we Monday
was great keeping the positive vibes
right okay I hopefully I can help with
this
Warrington I've been to Warrington not
much in Warrington based in Leeds when
Monday wasn't very motivating well
hopefully I can help with that Alice I
cleared out my spice drawer Wow
Horsham bedroom recruiter Monday was
okay missing off his wives definitely
same missing off of office wives are
sure people being kicked out my study by
over half love that my M good to see
wicked right so so chats in there Q&A
whenever you want to ask your questions
do that but thank you so much for
joining me
so as I go into the objectives here as I
go into the objectives a lot of you've
asked some really good questions so just
to frame this up I plan on doing more of
these so if I don't get
the opportunity to answer your question
I would do my utmost follow-up after
this webinar in answer it to you
personally but there's clearly loads of
stuff that you guys would really like
some advice on or help with on the
personal branding piece so with that
what I've done today the first one of
these is I have focused on what the hell
you guys going to be doing today to give
value to your market share content build
your brand when everyone is talking
about the coronavirus and Linkedin is
super noisy right so that that's been my
focus and yeah so the objectives today
really simple is just I really want all
of you today the fact that you're here
says a lot but I want you all to
understand the actual opportunities that
you all have to build your brand as a
recruiter that's where I'm going to
start I'm gonna give you some just real
practical tips and ideas on how you can
start building your brand today tomorrow
within the current landscape and
hopefully all of you can leave excited
to start sharing content on LinkedIn and
that does not mean start sharing your
job post that doesn't count and
hopefully we can have some fun I didn't
really I didn't enjoy school so for you
to be in your bedroom right now whatever
you are to feel like you're back at
school would be my worst nightmare so
hopefully that that doesn't isn't the
case so I'm gonna start with I'm gonna
start Q&A okay cool so the questions
coming in and loads of stuff in here
already I'm going to look at those so
let on its going to crack on with this
and start with my story so just to give
you a bit of context because I've been
in your shoes and it's important for you
to know that so what what's my story
right so quite simply it started with a
dream I realize today that on PDFs and
slides the gifts don't work which really
mine but we've all we've all seen that
Leonardo da Vinci seen wool falls free
spraying the cash and and my ice my
recruitment journey really did start
with a dream and that was the the
recruitment dream I worked in the
insurance industry
and one of my friends who then left the
insurance industry said to me hisham I
think you'd be good at recruitment and I
was like okay tell me more I'd love to
know more about it and what he proceeded
to tell me was the typical you're gonna
earn a shitload of cash in your first
year we're talking six figures you're
definitely gonna go to Ibiza and you
should be able to afford a Rolex now the
reality of that was was more this that
was my car a Renault Clio and I had a
gift there which didn't really work but
I didn't how I didn't make much money at
all my first year was really tough and I
could definitely afford casio leonardo
da vinci yeah definitely [ __ ] that heart
and it was a really tough first year in
in in recruitment and my my biggest
challenge was I couldn't get hold of
enough clients and candidates that I
could help that was my biggest challenge
in in my first year in recruitment so in
my first year recruitment I made 0
pounds out of LinkedIn I recruited in
the insurance market every single person
I spoke to hung out there and how I got
taught to use LinkedIn I joined a small
business and I learned from everyone
within my four walls Eliot starts burry
one of those who just messaged and then
how I got taught to use LinkedIn was
very simple hisham when you get a job
post about it okay I'm gonna do that
really easy when you send out LinkedIn
in males don't copy and paste the whole
message send out as many as you can try
make them personal and that was my
LinkedIn training right that's how I
used it but first in recruitment
I made zero pounds at LinkedIn and in my
office people were having some success
and using LinkedIn but we definitely
weren't using it effectively besides the
normal routes that know that all of you
guys do which is in males being
proactive
using all the same tools that every
single recruiter has right so got into
my second year recruitment and my old
boss said to me let he/she um I've seen
a lot of recruiters in my time and you
need to keep doing what we've taught you
which is smashing the phone's database
switchboards job boards wherever it may
be
just keep smashing the phones it's gonna
pay off
alright you've got that you've got the
work ethic you put in the volume of
activity in recruitment is a long game
keep them what you're doing and it will
pay off right and I was in a small
business so of course I was going to
take on that advice and listen and
that's what I continued to do going into
my second year recruitment but what I
decided to do was think about what else
could I do to give myself the best
possible chance of having more success
in recruitment and what it came down to
was LinkedIn essentially that was the
only other tool that I could maximize
that I had at my fingertips
so I I went outside of my falls of
recruitment and look what my competitors
were doing right and this was the light
bulb moment so this picture his mentor
don't ting a light bulb but what could I
learn from my competitors right and what
I saw and was that moment was like hang
on a minute there's a huge opportunity
here so this is what I saw and I took
these screenshots not too long ago these
were my competitors and back in the day
and it was just the same old [ __ ] I'm
working with well-established insurance
broker recruiting looks Pete's a
candidate it's just just terrible job
post right and um I know having worked
in recruitment for a year I now knew
this didn't make money none of us in the
office made it a single placement by
doing one of these fantastic job ads
right but that's how I was using it and
that's how I got taught to use it and I
was that person that I was I was using
LinkedIn the exact same way and that was
the light bulb moment for me because I
knew that if I could if I could use
LinkedIn a different way and gain a
competitive advantage against his
competitors then I was up for that I
don't know what other people's my
it's alike but for me if I didn't get a
client or candidate exclusive they were
going to get contacted by those guys
that I just showed you I knew who they
were and who their names were and
[ __ ] hated them I would do anything
to beat my competition or to have an
upper hand I'd have a competitive
advantage so that's when I made the
decision that I'm going to use LinkedIn
differently and that was the opportunity
that I saw and my whole motivation was
to stand out against my competition
right so my content journey didn't start
with videos it was actually pretty
cringy right so the next couple of
slides is just me documenting my journey
and what I started sharing content and
what that looked like I definitely
didn't start with videos I was too
scared to do that and a lot of people
think that they need to start with
videos to get started but they most
certainly do not what I started with was
quite quite cringy so hopefully you can
all see that but if you can it's very
simply me saying if you hate mondays
love mondays again that's how creative I
was good start and I just didn't want to
talk about jobs that was the one rule
that I gave myself so why I started to
do and this was when we was allowed to
go outside more than once and touch
people and I started to document what I
was up to in the market or as I said I
recruited in the insurance market and
something that we were really passionate
about and what we've sold to our clients
and candidates which I'm sure a lot of
you do as well is we actively get
involved in our industry we attend
networking events we attend learning
seminars we actively contribute to the
industry that we recruit in and get
involved with so what I started to do
and I had already been doing this in
year one was I just made sure that I
became that annoyin person that took a
picture guys gonna just take a picture
while we're doing this by blah blah and
some of these posts which and very
quickly start to gain more engagement
and were different and were just simple
pictures of what we're doing in the
industry so far left me my i'll boston
i'll colleague learning seminar in the
middle it was me and my
and then on the far right it was a
candidate that I placed up to count for
four drinks so I started to to get
better at sharing content on LinkedIn
that wasn't just job post and it started
with no creative input it started by me
documenting my journey as a recruiter
and what was up to in the market what I
was doing and because I wanted to make
sure that what I was saying on the phone
and what I was saying in the meetings I
was someone as passionate about the
industry I'd get involved and meet my
clients and meet my candidates our ten
learning seminars I get involved in my
industry was also demonstrated online
and - because that was the persona that
I wanted to create and that and and it
was true because that's what I was doing
so I wanted to make sure people knew
that so I then start to build some
confidence right this is this is the
thing when you start which is the
hardest part when you start sharing
content you then become more confident
with it like anything right so I then
decided to start sharing some videos I
had the genius idea that we're gonna
start sharing videos this was back into
2017 so this is but I couldn't even
share videos from my own profile at this
point my old boss had to share it and
the idea here was was really simple I
didn't really enjoy writing hated Ryan C
B's and therefore if I can share video
content and get myself across and in a
minute two minute video and get my
personality across I think that sounds
like a good idea
and so I started sharing videos and I
very simply started with an introductory
video and which lost out still now
recommend to people in terms of doing an
introductory post and I just started
with look everyone I've been connected
with you for a while this is this is me
this is the industry that I came from
this these are the people that I now
help these are the businesses that I now
help and I'm gonna be sharing more video
content any feedbacks welcome any ideas
etc and then I just came up with ideas
when the conversations like the
interview feedback really simple quite
generic one and but it's something that
we're really passionate about so I just
wanted to sort of share that journey
there where I didn't start by sharing
videos I started by talking about hating
Mondays
Mondays again and being a bit cringy to
document and I was up to in the market
and then building confidence from there
and sort of through that process I got
better at understanding what works what
didn't what driving more engagement with
my market and these parts of things
right so during this process some of you
may know or listen to the podcast like a
host and this is something that I always
say to my clients and recruits to bear
in mind is that when you start putting
yourself out there getting out your
compass owner sharing content the full
of once you've actually done that the
full of starting a podcast and event
series doing the webinar it doesn't
become as frightening it doesn't become
it doesn't appear as much as a challenge
if you've already put yourself out there
right so this is the thing here loads of
recruitment businesses do host events
and they're really successful and they
do really well but I guarantee if you've
got used to put yourself out there
sharing content these ideas that you may
have and not going to be you're not
gonna be are scared to do them basically
is what trying to say and that's
definitely what happened with me so
through that process I start the podcast
which is called the recruitment
rollercoaster podcast and that's how the
huge impacts on on my career and sort of
where I've ended up huge impacts and
that just became from me making that
single decision of I'm gonna use
LinkedIn differently and the one wrong
and give myself is is no more jobs so
then let me take my job hooks I media I
moved up to London and I joined an
inbound marketing agency that literally
worked with the recruitment industry
that's what I did for and just over a
year and then it then it's then led me
to start my own business and that's
really simple it's to help passionate
recruiters build their personal brands
so they can reach more people they can
help impact more lives and in turn make
more money which is obviously the pomace
whiners we won this branding and your
brand to coincide of everything else
that you're doing and we want it to be a
solid part of your toolbox to help you
build money as a recruiter right so
that's actually sort of my story as to
how I got to where I got to you today so
this is what I want you guys to let me
know in on the look at the questions in
the sack like what is your perception of
personal branding like show me in the
chat light what does it mean to you what
does personal branding means for you
it's it's definitely a buzzword a lot of
people talk about on LinkedIn you may
have seen it pop up way more often over
the last year or so but what is your
perception of personal branding what
does it mean to you as a recruiter Paul
Kelly is everything yeah
anyone else look at these questions do
you know I've had course on your
questions that it's everything
specialists in your setting you have
more value to ads how many of my market
know about me reputation Matthew ger
that god I'm gonna get on ROI for sure
having an opinion authenticity being
authentic yeah
catchphrase his purse brand hope is he
by clients can attend the mock from your
online presence yeah okay cool
sweet so and I think we can all agree
right the why that's important as a
recruiter is it's it's [ __ ] saturated
like it is very competitive and I think
that you could Google right now how many
recruitment businesses there are in in
the UK alone and you're gonna get all
different numbers but I think it's safe
to say that it's a lot we're talking
easily circa thirty thousand recruitment
businesses let alone how many recruiters
so it's competitive right which is why
it's important it's important that you
can reach as many people as possible and
for these people to have some sort of
perception of you online it's a perfect
thank you for sharing that that's great
so for me quite simply this is the
really simple definition it's what you
guys said personal branding is a
practice of marketing people and their
careers brands right it is not rocket
science ultimately it's all about you
what people say about you when you're
not in the room how you're perceiving
what makes you you so you get that right
it's it's not rocket science you all
understand that and we understand why
it's important
so just to sort of tie us all together
these are the people that come to mind
for me when I hear the word personal
brand the likes of Gary Vaynerchuk Will
Smith Dwayne Johnson Conor McGregor
Kylie Jenner and for me the real power
in this guy's is that it's that whole
cliche people buy from people and your
clients your candidates they work with
you which is an extension of the
business that you work for but
ultimately these people work with you as
recruiters right and you have those
relationships so the real power in this
is that people human beings can drive
emotions can drive feelings can drive
people to do stuff and fill certain
things and perceive you in certain ways
way easier than a company can right
you're a human being the end of day
which is why there's a lot of power in
Conor McGregor starting there a whisky
brand somewhere I'm making a shitload of
cash right because all of a sudden
people think if y'all buy that then I'm
like Conor McGregor right so being like
people buy from people and this is why
it's really powerful right even more so
in in recruitment so we understand that
and this is just the punch line really
and this is what I've recognized sitting
down with loads of recruiters and some
of you probably been in in the
recruitment industry longer than I have
but the best recruit is 100 percent
already have a personal brand it's their
reputation it's why they get referrals
it's you deliver them for your clients
and candidates however typically what I
found is a lot of recruiters brands has
remained offline and what I mean by that
is your reputation how you're perceived
how clients and candidates talk about
you is staying and residing within the
one-on-one phone calls it's staying in
the one-on-one meetings it's staying in
the four walls of your meeting rooms
that's where it's staying right now
because a lot of you if I were to look
at your LinkedIn profile right now now
and to see who you are and you just
called me right if you give me if you BD
me and I look at your profile is this
cool I mean what real creative blah blah
blah I look at your profile I guarantee
you're going to look like just the next
recruiter right even though when we get
on the phone you're gonna tell me this
is one different this is how
work this one passion about this is how
I delivered for other people etc etc
right so for me all of you already have
a reputation you already have a personal
brand but a lot of the time it's just
stayed offline right and and this is the
whole sort of piece in now why the the
shop front window your online presence
needs to make sure that it's
communicating the things we're going to
be sound on the phone and and that's
that's the opportunity at the end of the
day so a neck I'm going to wrap up with
this but an exercise that I would love
you all to do because it's eye-opening
and it should hopefully motivate you is
this is every single recruiter that I
work with I get them to send me to
direct competitors actual individuals
not businesses and what I will do is
look at what they're doing online what
are what are your competitors doing in
your market how are they leveraging
LinkedIn what they're talking about
how are they using it and I've seen
easily well over 200 recruiter profiles
now by doing this and honestly they all
at the same
95% of recruiters on LinkedIn you may
not think if you're connected with
rhetoric so it connects with some of the
suppliers you may think everyone's doing
video now and all these types of things
but honestly they're not there's
humongous amount of opportunity right
now for you guys to cut through and
stand out amongst your competitors and
yes LinkedIn is very noisy right now but
trust me I would really recommend just
having a quick look okay what are the
people doing that I come up against
actively in the market and hopefully
that would leave you guys motivated to
take action and I'd do that because
that's what I did for myself and it was
a huge motivator for me it really was so
that's one of the exercises that I would
I would love you to to look at and do
after this webinar so let's look at I'm
going to look at some questions are you
sending these flags that's like remember
it all yeah so I will be sending all the
slides out and I've got some stuff too
that you can all download as well after
so I'll give all of this out so
let's move on so when I started my
business I want to come up a really
simple process that I can communicate to
recruiters about and take them free when
working with them because honestly you
guys are smart this is not rocket
science it's just understanding how to
start what to start with in these types
of things which is typically the
challenge but the proven process that
I've taken a lot of recruiters free now
and is what I like to call the free
Pease forbidden your personal brand and
I'm gonna touch on some of these today P
for purpose P for plan P for paying for
words right and that's more of a mindset
piece so the first part is P for purpose
so like anything right even more so in
times like this and I'm definitely
challenging and I'm definitely finding
it challenging but right now in the
current market you need to understand
why you're doing what you're doing like
if if you're not sure on why you're
doing what you're doing right now it's
gonna be difficult to be motivated every
single day in your living room on your
kitchen desktop right so for me building
your brand as a recruiter and needs to
be more than just to make your manager
happy or I'm doing it because my boss
said I need to do more LinkedIn right so
those questions there why do you want to
invest in your personal brand and how do
you want it to help you in your
recruitment career it's something that
you should really think about and
understand that's just going to help you
understand and why you want to do more
LinkedIn and why building a brand is
important because when you when you do
share content and you feel like no one
is listening which I certainly did at
the beginning when not many people
engage your content no get as many likes
as you wanted you don't get as many
comments and if you're not really sort
of honed in on why you're doing and why
it's important to you and it's gonna be
a good chance that you're gonna stop
before you even started right so I'd
really encourage all of you to just
understand why you're here today wanting
the less about personal branding and why
how you want it to impact the
recruitment career and yes we want to
tell you make more money but I think
it's got there's got to be a bit more to
it than that you definitely do
recruitment for more than just
for the money right so I'm gonna segue
into and I'm gonna segue into like right
now like my my opinion on sort of what
your branding efforts should look like
and just my faults really which on a
share bein and I'll segue into questions
because there's quite a few in there so
we'll do that and Matt older you've got
a dry cloth have you been tested for
crony yet cheers mate no I haven't been
tested come on I can't say that every
songs on coughs now bit bit harsh and so
for me right now this is my opinion on
how you should be thinking about your
branding efforts and how what your
mindset should be towards personal
branding like for me your objective
right now should be the sort of analogy
I've tried to use is be the lighthouse
or your market and what I mean by that
is yes you can talk about coronavirus
yes we can talk about work from home and
your market definitely thinking about
these things but for me the opportunity
that you'll have and how you should be
approaching this is like you guys should
be the place where candidates and
clients are going to hear about the
challenges people in the market economy
facing the solutions that you're hearing
on the phones on the video calls how
people are onboarding people remotely
how people are interviewing remotely
what are the solutions that your hiring
managers your candidates are coming up
with that you're speaking to on a daily
basis what do they look like and also to
be communicating or sharing content
around how people are adapting in your
market right and that that for me is
sort of what the mindset should be
towards your personal brand right now
become that lighthouse of your market
become the place where people go to
learn from other people and what other
people are doing in these challenging
times and Matthew go dad should you keep
it strictly business related or would
you also include personal content for
more authenticity
I'll get this question a lot and
honestly Matthew and anyone else is
thinking that and for me I'm sure like
you've seen on LinkedIn like that sort
of everyone you should go
in this business Facebook is personal
right they're very they are hundred
percent crossing over and I think lots
of things safe to say that they've
always sort of crossed over like me as a
work person it's definitely some there's
definitely similarities to me as just
down the pub with my mates and I think
that's very much korsunova so I think
being human on LinkedIn and sharing if
you wanna call it personal content is
100% something that you should be done
and I think there's nothing wrong with
that I think all I would say and
hopefully other people benefit from this
just because I had that question I think
that's valuable is the let's say for
example I took I took a picture right
now of of me going for a walk and on the
beach right in my one dose of exercise
that I get and I took a picture and
let's say I posted that on Instagram or
Facebook the caption that I may put on
that is views that's a caption I might
use that cuz I think that sounds a bit
cool and I want people to look at me and
go I wish I was at a beach like that
right if I use that same picture and
posted it on LinkedIn all we've got to
do here it would be a bit smart and
respect the people in the room the
people that are hanging out on LinkedIn
and use the context of that to
understand what we should be talking
about so what I mean by that is if you
could use that same picture post on
LinkedIn and say really grateful at the
moment to be able to and walk in these
sorts of places in this one dose of
exercise at the moment and one of the
challenges that I'm having right now
work from home is work/life balance
I'm working in the kitchen I'm working
in the living room I'm finding it hard
to switch off some of the things some of
the things that I've started to do and
implement in my day is I've done a bit
of I've made sure I'll do some exercise
in the morning I don't made sure I
always go for a walk on a daily basis
this is how it sort of helped me get
through the challenging times at the
moment and how without work/life balance
how are other people managing their
wildlife balance at home same picture
same picture are you talking about a bit
differently right and it's that sort of
business
or you just respect in the room so hope
that answer your question Matt but I
think it's it's just you say personal
but I think it's it's just the
conversations if you have been right
when on a bit of a tangent there but I
felt like that was necessary okay Keith
look what I'm gonna get to the questions
in the set so okay he shemagh Elliot
this makes sense what the hell do I talk
about online right this is easily the
most common challenge I get from
recruiters even more so in the current
climate right so I'm gonna just really
dive deep now into like what you guys
could be talking about and I'm just
gonna give you some ideas and the
conversations I'm having and hopefully
this helps right but what I think is
fair to say is there really is now
starting to feel like a bit of a
coronavirus fatigue and what i mean by
that is like we've all we've all spoke
like the amount of times that we've said
the amount of times we said coronavirus
last week or the week before i'd like to
think is starting to to reduce like we
understand what it is we understand
what's going on and we're sort of going
into acceptance we understand we accept
what's going on right now we need to
focus on what we can control and we're
trying to innovate we're trying at that
and we've accepted the coronavirus
exists and it's a real thing and it's
it's it's happening right so and I think
like we and I think we've seen an influx
for people talking about coronaviruses
what's going on what do people think is
it like the like coronavirus fatigue
that it's hundred seven happening and we
get it right the next thing is once
you've spoken about work from home this
is my set up look at me this is the two
screens that I've got I definitely
haven't got this set up by the way and I
wish I had but once we've done that what
we're going to talk about right and
that's all I wanted to do this is
because right now you may think I've got
a lot of time I've always wanted to the
sauce that starts sharing more content
what can idea is great opportunity but
once I spoken about Koran of on I should
I be speaking about the crown of virus
or once I've shared people what my work
from home set up is what the how do I
talk about right
so I'm gonna try and give you some ideas
so just some really basic marketing
principles right and you can all
understand this this is this is not
rocket science and this is all you need
to understand it is not complicated
coronavirus or no coronavirus what do we
think makes good content for a second
light when i say to you what do you
think makes good content
what would you say put it put it in
there in the public chat like when i
what do you think makes content good
content what comes up what comes up for
you guys when i say that please do share
I'd love to just get people's
perspective of this because I think
it'll be interesting I'm gonna look up
questions in the meantime how do you
made your personal branding and some
good ones in life solutions
anything relatable relevance engage in
innovative useful something thats boxed
about yeah advice for those who've lost
jobs stands out something that has
valued someone that work yeah
exactly so there's all different things
here right but for me I think the
punchline of all this right come yeah we
want it to be valuable stand out etc etc
right and some of the people can relate
to again relevance I think for me what
the for me again we don't need to over
complicate this right you may think of
sales people you're not marketers but
this this this is not difficult to
understand so for me it really is simple
its its content as relevant right when
I'm when I'm on my phone and I see a
post I read something I watch something
I listen to something nothing ah that's
really relevant to my world right now or
I can really relate to that
but that's what's going to give you the
best possible chance of stopping your
candidates and clients in their tracks
to go are this is interested in what
they've got to say whatever right so for
me that's all I want you to think about
when we're talking about content
what makes engage in blah blah blah let
all you need to know is okay I want to
meet if I'm sharing content I want to
make sure that it's relevant to my
target audience and those Talk That Talk
audience is simply your candidates and
clients or if you're an internal
recruiter
people you trying to have your business
that's all is content that is relevant
for your target audience right and okay
so in order to come up with content that
gives you the best possible chance of
being relevant right for me and this is
how I did one on recruitment you need to
think about your daily conversations
right now this is what I want you all to
remember you speak to your target
audience on a daily basis and you have
even more access to them right now the
things that you constantly keep talking
about on the phone or new zoom video
cause is exactly what we want to be
bringing to life with your content and
with your brand these are the things
that I'd like to think is going to give
you guys confidence that like if you'll
speak to a hiring manager that's really
find it difficult to onboard people
remotely or whatever it may be there's
hundreds ain't gonna be able hormone
users are worrying about that I'm gonna
have that headache so that again we
don't use over complicate this think
about your conversations the same
conversations you have in like that's
what we need to think about right and
and this is what's going to help us
understand what you should be talking
about so for me I'd really encourage all
of you to do this write this down
wherever it is that I'm gonna send the
slides but just ask yourself this
question and really think about it what
are the biggest headaches and challenges
that your clients um facing right now
what are they running about
yes coronavirus but how is this impact
in their business how is this impacting
their life professionally and personally
same with candidates what are their
biggest headaches and challenges that
they're facing one other might be made
redundant what the challenges that are
faced in how has that impacted their
their life person in professionally
right these if if you really dig deep
into these questions and think about
this quit these questions when you're
speaking to people which you'll be
finding this sort of stuff out anyway as
recruiters right so this is how I want
you to think about the the content you
should be talking about
so what these try to do here just sort
of spit ball some of the things that
come up for me in the conversation I'm
having right so beyond coronavirus yes
coronaviruses a challenge yes
coronaviruses challenge for candidates
but how is this impacting them is it
managing their teams remotely is it
keeping their team's morale up remotely
is it ensuring their employees mental
well-being as being taken care of is it
on board a new star from earlier is it
getting the necessary tech delivered to
new staff like laptops is it not having
access to other business owners
homeowners you have taken OnStar from
only before is it work from home whilst
looking after their children that's how
we dig a bit deeper into this beyond
coronavirus for candidates is it
communicating with their teams
effectively is it managing their own
mental well-being is it being more is it
being made redundant not understand when
the opportunities are in the market
right now he's not knowing how to make
sure they're ready for the bounce-back
etc etc we get we get what I'm trying to
talk about here is that you need to be
thinking about the conversations you're
having and these are the things that you
should be sharing content about right
because a lot of people are gonna be
having the same headaches okay and all
we're doing here to tie this together
basic marketing is we're starting to
build out our target audience client and
candidate persona and all the persona is
and marketing terms is it's a semi
sectional representation of your ideal
customer it's in recruitment context
it's your ideal candidate or client and
this this is what all marketing agencies
will do for them to create content that
gives them the best possible chance of
resonating with people that they want to
buy their product engage with their
service engage with them is they need to
make content that's going to be relevant
for their target audience for the people
that they can serve or sell to right so
all it is is you guys starting to think
about who your ideal client and
candidate are and because you speak to
clients and candidates on a daily basis
and you have your own networks the same
headaches that your hiring managers that
you have relation with right now it's
very likely the hiring manager that
you're not working whether that's on
your target BD list is going to be
having the same challenges
- that that's that's the content piece
and like I'm just trying to tackle here
like how to form ideas because that is
the most common question that all of you
sent me is how the hell door comment of
ID is right and right now for me I think
the ideas and always have been anyway in
your conversations but just bring into
life the solutions that people come up
with the challenges etc so yeah once you
think about comical content ideas this
way you are gonna be surprised how much
ease think about what you'll be talking
about online right so ultimately it's
the video causing the phone
conversations that we bring to life
that's what we should be talking about
and my best advice for this is actually
I think I might be able to share this
with you now you share so I never shared
that I've never used this hand that hand
out thing before but you should be able
to click at the top where it says chat
Q&A
maybe I'll to see polls a lot but you
should see handouts and I've just shared
a handout called facilitating
conversations and you should be able to
download that
so hopefully you should all get if
someone can just mess up message on the
chat zone yeah I can get that document
or consider then just can you just
message on their send yeah I can get it
so that's great but I've just shared a
document which is which gives you my
best advice on how you should be
approaching talking about the topics
that I'm just talking about and for me
it's the facilitating conversation of
your content right and like so that have
it have a read of that but that's that's
what my best advice and quite simply I'd
want to go into a bit more detail but on
answer your your questions which one
within a sec and is ultimately because
once you've got the ideas likely your
challenge then is what you're gonna give
me as Hisham I don't want to come across
one way to my market I don't want to say
the wrong thing I don't come across
unprofessional so the advice that I've
been given all that my crimes have been
working with which is help them overcome
that challenge is to facilitate
conversations around the topics that you
know are relevant and important to your
market and so for me any sort of topic
you can approach it in the way of this
is what I'm hearing the mark
this is what people are telling me and
then you pull it back on your network
what am i network think that it's what
are people's thoughts on this and it's
encouraging people to engage and share
their thoughts so it might be for
example and everyone's work from home at
the moment and I'm speaking to loads of
candidates in my market that finding it
really challenging the common challenges
I'm hearing from candidates in my market
is that they find it really hard to to
be parents whilst also being being a
tech developer and they're finding hard
to manage their mental well-being the
finite hearts of work-life balance
whatever it may be these are the
challenges I'm hearing what do you guys
think how are other people coping
however of what the other challenges
that people going through right now
what do people think of this let me know
your thoughts right and you can always
again your being that in that medium of
facilitating conversations on the right
topics the relevant topics and what that
means is you don't have to jump on line
and say I'm right you're wrong because
that's where people get worried right if
you jump online and go this is why every
single business should have had flexible
working I'm right you're all wrong
you're gonna be worried that other
people are gonna comment on that and go
shut the [ __ ] up basically it'd be
really negative and you're worried about
that which is fine but this is my advice
on facilitating conversations it's to
approach it with this is what I'm here
in the market this is what people are
telling me what do you guys think and
you become the medium of this type of
conversation and that's a good place for
you to start to overcome that challenge
of I'm worried about people bearing me
online which I totally get right so to
sort of find the lies the ideas part
this is something really practical that
you can do at any time coronavirus no
coronavirus this is something that I've
always got my clients to do right so we
fall about what makes what what what
things are relevant right now and the
conversations that's what I've told you
but again you speak to your target
audience so for me right now I would
literally get on the phone and speak to
your clients and candidates that know
that you're doing already and ask them
the direct question of a lot of really
one
sure that juniors period I want to give
value to my network help where I can
and one of those one of the things that
I can do is share content that you
should find useful or share content you
should find valuable what content right
now would you find valuable what content
right now would you find useful in the
current crime map you can go out and
this is another touch point for you and
your your clients and candidates you can
get on the phone and do this look I hope
you don't mind me giving you a quick
call one is check in and also look I'm
planning on trying to do more links and
over this period to make sure I do my
part and how you don't mind me asking
but what what would you find really
useful right now if I was to start
sharing content on that right you could
start doing this you could go and ask
five ten of your people the best
relationships with find out what they
want you share content about it and
guess what you can do then hey Adam you
know that conversation we had the other
day and look I've just put a post out
about it have a look at it let me know
what you think right and we driving
people to it and it's going to drive
engagement right that's just some real
practical advice and another exercise
that one you ought to do after this
webinar so what have I seen recruiters
do well so far in this that I think that
I'm just going to give you some ideas
now and then I'm gonna ask questions
ideas so why I've seen that's been
really interested in and hopefully you
can see that um okay but Jamie Walker is
a recruiter and what he's what they've
decided to do is they they've recognized
that people start to do obviously way
more video interviews and a lot of
people never done them before so what
they've decided to do is run a free
video workshop or video interview
workshop free one-on-one whatever it may
be interview preparation workshop where
ever it may be free video and they're
gonna facilitate that and do that and
give value that way that is a Content
idea that's something you can do with
your brand right now right I think
that's a great idea
I know that's not sure on how where you
can see that so apologies I wasn't sure
but basically only Perry had him
recently on a podcast webinar that I did
and he has teamed up collaborated with
his colleagues and they are hosting a
webinar a bit like this which is not
difficult to start or you could do it
for resume it's really easy and they're
just gonna give value
answer questions about how to adapt and
how to cope in the current climate in
their markets right great idea you could
all do that
Tom Hurley his event unfortunately got
canceled so what do they decide to do
make it into a online roundtable of them
zooom invite people to a video call get
hiring managers leaders in your market
everyone's going for challenges right
now let's be the place where we
facilitate decent conversations around
the challenge that going on right now
you could do that resume really easily
that is not difficult not a great idea
Chris Sycamore what he's decided to do
is he's called it the sycamore surgery
so again because now you may all feel
like you have more time and you want to
do things like this
he's he's made the decision to open up
his diary at 2:00 p.m.
looking free 15-minute and consultations
to give pratik advice to people in his
market great idea you could all do that
book in the meet in engaging me what you
worried about right now I'd love to just
give you my two pens that are there
right these are all great ideas that you
can all action and you could all do for
your market definitely so ideas that you
could action just to finalize this is
these are just some of the things that
just came up for me when I was preparing
for this start of what's that group of
homeowners in your market to collaborate
share ideas and challenges host is in
video call the candidate should be made
redundant to offer advice on making sure
their CV is in shape links and profiles
and check and are prepared for the
bounce back open up your diary like
Chris 15-20 minutes lots is simply
Network ask your ask you for advice and
receive help host a virtual roundtable
with senior people in your market to
facilitate conversations around what the
hell's going on right now right these
are all things that you could do I think
they're great ideas so next thing say
yeah so just quickly I'm going to
questions now recap of tasks recap of
actions that I love you guys to take
because it for you to start building
your brand it's going to require actions
is firstly I would wonder percent
recommend looking at your competitors
what they didn't want I was have a quick
look yes you've got prioritize your time
yes you may think I don't need to look
at my competitors I need to focus on
winder nyet that's fine but have a look
at what they are doing and hopefully
you'll see what the opportunities are
coz there's a very good chance that all
they're doing is spamming their newsfeed
with jobs right and we know that doesn't
make money so I wouldn't have a look and
go right what why actually people into
my market right now I'm not not people
that have a good brand people that wake
up every single morning that are trying
to take money out of your pocket because
they're your competitor what are they
doing because you're trying to speak to
the same people have a look at what
they're doing hopefully actually
motivate you get 5 content ideas
directly from your candidates or clients
by asking them the direct question of I
want to share more content during this
period that you should find valuable
useful what would you love me to talk
about right now get 5 content ideas from
your clients and candidates I feel
confident you could all do that and then
the final task with that is to post
about them share one post over the next
7 days that is giving value to your
market and if you're really worried
about what this is what I blog about
drop me a message on LinkedIn I'm happy
to help right but I'm very confident
that you could do that and you should
aim to do that in the next 7 days so
I've got the most common questions asked
here but I'm gonna dive into the Q&A
guys if you if you really want to get
your questions answered and then feel
free to to getting these questions so I
start the top question from Baron
Jeffries what's your strategy for
creating content for LinkedIn quickly so
for me it take it takes time is one just
conscious of their Baron is what I'm
thinking about yes we want it to be as
efficient as possible timewise so how I
would answer this and I hope this
answers the question for you guys and is
I would split up your time so what I
find is a lot of recruiters will go
right on Friday 3 to 4 p.m. on them I'm
gonna write content for next week on the
right all my content for next week I've
blocked out time I'm going to do it and
they go into that time and and they're
also using that time they blocked out to
come up with the idea
what they're gonna talk about and write
the LinkedIn post all right or do the
video whatever right and what tends to
happen is you go into that time and you
look at your screen and you end up
banging your head against the screen
going what the [ __ ] I'm not gonna create
content about right so what to answer
question Baron is I would say split your
time into let's say 2 30 minutes
1 30 minutes on what common come what
what common conversations I've I had
this week that have come up more than
twice with clients with candidates jot
those down in bullet points and their
your content ideas and pick what one or
two that you want to create content
about so you just split up your time
with thinking about what you want to say
and actually writing or recording or
whatever it is that with the actual
content so think of the actual ideas and
then separate your time with then making
the time to actually create it for me
there's just no shortcut like it takes
time it does so I think what we'll make
it effectively just using the
conversations you have and I've said
this a lot but I think that's the best
place to start and we'll help it happen
quickly because you're on the phone so
hopefully that answers your question
Baron so next one so Matt order yet oh
you're on are you sending these slides
out yes I will be doing that I can do
that now actually so let me just preview
yeah post Brendan right so you should
all get the slides okay right so I'm
going to jump into this away from
LinkedIn what is the the most powerful
social media platform you use to promote
your personal brands I'll be completely
honest with this that's from Campbell
Barlow I'll be completely honest to this
Campbell I mainly use LinkedIn that's
that's the short answer
so and the reason for that is because
and that's where my target audience hang
out my target audience is recruiters and
I think for me we don't overcomplicate
it so my question back would be how much
how much money or how much of your
Billings revenue is generated from
LinkedIn right I'd like two fingers it
could be quite hard percentage how many
kind of actually registering or getting
through
in now how many clients are you getting
how much of your how much of your
Billings is coming from LinkedIn right
and if it's a pretty decent percentage
and you know and that answer that
question is very percent forty percent
sixty percent all my candidates come
from LinkedIn just focus on LinkedIn
just focus on the one platform we don't
need to think about anything else right
now
like and you want to start in the place
which is gonna give you the best
possible chance of helping you make
money because we want this to help you
make money the other day where you're
going to have the best possible chance
for success that would be my listen to
that campbell martin smith how often
would you recommend putting personal
content out there good question
don't think there's a perfect amount but
i think if you were to let's say on a
weekly basis post twice and one post was
making sure that we're talking about
relevant things that are going on in
your market right now and the other post
might be about documenting you
personally what your how your business
is going how you're doing as a parent
managing your kids whilst being a
recruiter once a week of either of those
i think is a good blend but honestly i
wouldn't overthink it I really wouldn't
I think they they they cross over I
think it's about it's about sharing that
personal content through the business
lens it's both I really did if I think
of the post that I share its I don't
think about oh is this another personal
post or whatever it's yeah I think just
don't overthink that but I think one's
one of each wouldn't be a bad place to
start so hope that answers your question
Martin Jordan black when doing the
introduction video if you are new to
recruitment do you feel this may
discredit you he has only done this for
a few months he can't help me I totally
understand that challenge Jordan and I'd
totally appreciate that
what I would push back and say is what
you say how are you approaching it on
the phone I'm sure you're not I'm sure
you're saying that look this is this is
the company I work for this is the types
of people that I help I've been here for
four months
how can help you do the like I'm sure
you're not lead them with or having the
mentality that you can't help them right
so what I would say Jordan and this
actually came out of a podcast like that
which was really interesting it was with
a guy called Lloyd Hume who works for a
business called trust in so that there
are a tech recruitment business and like
that this is one of the main challenges
I get Jordan from people that have been
in recruiting that long is they are
worried of well like you said this
credit in yourself or come across
unprofessional
so what Lloyd spoke about is that okay
well I'm Jordan you may not have all the
experience right now but downright your
business does your agency does in your
colleagues too so you can lead with that
that that's something you could
definitely do it
hi my name's Jordan I've been working
this business for four months and I'm
really eager to learn more about my
industry I'm actively reaching out to
people to understand what's going on in
their world how they operated by blah
blah and and the business I work for the
brand that I work for this is what we
specialize in let me tell you about our
business let me tell you about our
colleagues and how they can help you in
your business and you're part of that
right so I get sort of the worry there
but hopefully that that answers your
question and give you some ideas Jordan
and so if NCTM raise what answer over
fifty percent okay yeah Campbell so just
quickly back to that so cameras question
on LinkedIn should I worry about what
should I be thinking about other
platforms or whatever his answer them
was over 50% of his placements come from
LinkedIn so honestly guys do not worry
about other platforms right now I know I
saw Hannah you said about tick-tock I'm
not will to take over the recruitment
industry I have no idea I have no idea
what I'm focusing on right now and what
I think are we to focus on is what
what's current right now that that you
could be LinkedIn is not going anywhere
right so how can you maximize this
LinkedIn tool that all recruiters have
access to differently and that's what I
would focus on and okay right so I've
got some other questions in
so let me just go into these questions
guys if you really want me to answer
some questions and put them in here I'm
gonna just make my way through them
what would you recommend to do similar
to the meeting clients candidates if you
work in a different country to your
market yeah I could totally get that
it's an interesting that one I mean even
more so now when I'm so you're not gonna
be like if you did go over there every
now and again see yeah sorry Michael
wing wing Holmes question what would you
recommend to do similar to the meeting
clients candidates if you work in a
different country to your market I'd
like to think you are that you would be
doing some sort of video calls or these
types of things will you at least visit
the place if you don't understand that
so what I would say and what I've seen
work really well my core is let's say
you work you work that answer that
market not so you're based in UK if
you're seen as the recruiter that is
championing the Amsterdam tech market or
the Amsterdam financial services market
that is a good thing so what you could
say is or how you could communicate out
there's slightly different but you could
say I love talking to growing businesses
in in Amsterdam right now and the
economy is absolutely booming Amsterdam
this is what I'm saying blah blah blah
there's loads of opportunity in
Amsterdam right now and just be the
person that is putting your market which
is a different country on the pedestal
and I think that could be quite
effective
so maybe approach like that and if nor
if you're doing video calls or people
stuff like that you screenshot these
things and I always love communicating
with and Amsterdam business owners or
whatever and get screenshots of these
video calls and stuff like that
hopefully that helps Michael right ok
yeah so I've had quite a few but let me
just jump into me and two of us and not
look over from scratch oh no quite never
did it there when you're starting out it
needs to be open - okay cool so want to
do people as I appreciate it it's
getting towards 12:00 I'm gonna run over
anyone ask your questions about a cup of
questions on like how to measure this
right and it's and it's completely valid
so again we don't need to overcome
so the great thing with LinkedIn and
your personal account is you get all the
data you get all the information right
so this is how I break up I break it up
in awareness so the things you want to
be looking at is how many people are
looking at my profile is that going up
as it going down how many people might
connected with I might grow my network
and obviously that's gonna be you being
proactive but also people connecting
with you coming to you and saying I want
to connect with you so awareness your
connection network based growth your
profile views her growth and then the
amount of people that view your post
that that's really easy get all that
data right so how many people view in my
post right that's awareness how many
more people would know knowing that I
exist and know who I am
the next part is engagement and then
it's just like some comments right
really simple you can see all of that
information and I'd be measuring that am
i getting more am i getting less and
it's good to know what is getting more
and what isn't getting less because
that's going to help you understand we
should be talking more about and then
the last part is inbound opportunities
right and I use the word opportunities
when you're an actual human being a
person rather than inbound leaves and
stuff like that is because what I've
realized is when when you're a recruiter
that starts sharing content and you're
perceived as someone that's willing to
have an opinion on your marker you'll be
surprised with the opportunities that
you may get it may be that you may get
invited to go on a podcast and maybe
that you get invited to do a talk at an
event and maybe you get invited to a
roundtable / zoom inbound opportunities
right and then part of that is then
obviously people messaging you trust me
this this happens this is how I measure
it my clients and you will not forget it
right hi hi Jordan really enjoy your
concert at the moment we'd love to talk
to you about how you can help my
business or how to see if you can help
me progress my career that will happen
and you will get inbound messages like
that right now the challenge rivet is
you may get a lot of people that see
your content that don't engage they
don't like that don't message that
you're impacting but you can't see that
you can't measure that which I totally
understand so the other thing that I'd
sort of encourage you to sort of measure
maybe mentally this yes it's not data
and stuff like that as more qualitative
data is if you're
calling people and you're messaging
people when your speech them for the
first time or its existing clients or
whatever and they say on the phone or
they mention in the message and Jordan
and wasn't saying is sorry if they
mention it that they've been seeing your
content or Jordan I've been really
enjoying your content at the moment or
I've seen your videos you've done
recently like make sure that you know
those things like all those things small
wins always just remember those things
when I was a recruit if you do I was
doing the business development session
I've got through to someone for the
first time and I said hi my name's
Hisham azuz I work for pavilion
recruitment I'm a specialist insurance
creator blah blah blah
hi hm you know what actually I didn't
know who you are I've seen some of your
content but obviously it's hard to
measure that but I route you got
remember those conversations right so
the data points are awareness engagement
and then the inbound opportunities you
can very easily measure these things you
know these things and they're the things
that I'd be keeping an eye on so other
honest gets for you I'm gonna get for
you a few more questions and then we'll
end this so I've had a few things how
much content is too much and for me
honestly I think again
don't don't ever think that I think if
right now if you're not doing anything
then one post a week is great I think
that's a great position to be starting
is the most difficult thing so starting
with one post a week and building
confidence and momentum from there is
fine
you made your goal there might be doing
to post a week I think the most
important thing rather than thinking how
much you're too much is thinking about
the stuff that I am posting or the stuff
that I'm sharing and while making sure
it's relevant to my market right now
that that's what I'd rather you focus on
then it's too much too much I think one
post a week great position to be in two
posts a week wicked right that's maybe
what you should be aiming for but yeah
don't worry too much about too much or
too much because the end the day I don't
think if you're talking about stuff
that's relevant
I don't think too much is too much if
it's really if it's remaining relevant
to your market okay right so I'm gonna
get for your you more question questions
on this how do you so how do you measure
done that
how can content be used to target so
question from testify son how can
content be used to target the market and
most importantly how can we get past
financing metrics and get shares
comments and engagement so test so I
would really encourage you to look at
that document that I send on
facilitating conversations part of my
advice around that is if you're Pro if
you're with your content you're sort of
saying like and this is what I'm hearing
this one picking up on this is what I'm
seeing and then you're putting it back
in the network and saying what do you
guys think I would love to get people's
forts or how have people been overcoming
this challenge or put just posing a
question to your audience with your
content to sort of close it off and it
is a great way to drive comments and
engagement right and just a just a quick
one so hopefully that answers your
question but just a quick one on that
guys I'm going to share with you I think
we've gone through these things so we're
doing there so one of the things that
I'm just going to share with you now
just another document I will share my
clients is how to structure your
Linkedin post so that's that's just sort
of in line with and your question there
so I've just shared it all with you you
can download that and I've just really
simply just put in that how you should
structure your content and that's just
going to be the best possible chance
with drive and engagement so make sure
you will download that and test I hope
for that helps as well I'm gonna I'm
gonna answer I'm just going to answer
one more question
Elliot you've said how should you how
often should you post done that how
personal you get a link so I'm a big
believer that people okay so Nathan
Adams how personal do you get on
LinkedIn I'm a big believer that people
buy from people not mentioning jobs etc
do you think more your post about your
life than more people in brace you
really interesting question I think I
mean I think it's definitely the
contribute to that Nathan I really do
think that I think at the end of the day
like what you talk about on the phone
and you talking about your family you
talking about what you did on the
weekend these things come up in
conversation like if you're documenting
and sharing with your network that you
are someone that has set the goal this
week to run 5k or whatever it may be
other things anything wrong with that
because these things are gonna come into
your conversations
so I think what you'll find it Nathan
what really encouraged you to do and
this will really hopefully motivate you
is definitely look at your competitors
because what I find this ties in with
this point is so many recruiters online
don't look human they all at the same is
actually mentor like honestly so many
recruiters are just spamming their
newsfeed with jobs they've done it human
so on until Nathan if there's anything
that you can do with your content that
makes me feel like or helps me
understand what it might be like to work
with Nathan I think that's a great thing
and I think that's definitely to help
you so I hope that answers your question
so what so just to finish off guys and
I'm gonna I'm gonna do more of these and
it may just be loads more Q&A and answer
your questions and I just honestly just
wanted to say thank you
I really appreciate your time the first
time I've sort of done a webinar at
least on personal branding so honestly
any feedback and it's very much welcome
if you want any help with anything
obviously with LinkedIn personal
branding whatever honestly I'm happy to
help drop me a message I'm here to help
and remember the task I set you and I've
shared obviously the slide deck you'll
have all of that and I will try and sort
of come back to the majority of you on
the questions that you submitted
just drop your note and LinkedIn these
are my thoughts or whatever I hope that
helps but and yeah feedbacks really
welcome I hope you enjoyed it today I
really appreciate you and joining me
stay safe
I hope all your family as well and yeah
I just wanted to say a huge thank you it
means a lot
and then it's got a 10-second counter
thank you guys for for dropping a
message I would appreciate it